[Musique]
qui était marcel basque où l'art un
simple marginal ou un dessinateur génial
tombé dans l'oubli un clochard qui
vivait en ermite ou un provocateur dont
le comportement étrange indignée la
bonne société berruyères un travesti
farfelues ou un intellectuel incompris
il a passé sa vie à peindre et à
dessiner chaque rue chaque monument de
bronze
il a décelé des centaines d'oeuvres
aujourd'hui dispersés sa vie s'achève
tragiquement en 78 il meurt assassiné
comment est il devenu
près de quarante ans après sa mort une
signature dans le monde de l'art basque
où l'art un destin un destin tragique
basse classe et pas un personnage
monolithique c'est plein de facettes au
départ moi ce qui m'intéressait parce
que j'avais découvert c'est que bascoul
arrêté un témoin du la métamorphose de
la ville par exemple et dessine le la
première barre hlm d'avaricum où il
habitait lui et c'était ça qui
m'intéressait et puis sa vie qui est
quand même assez étonnant
ça commence par quasiment le meurtre de
son père par sa mère puis lui même est
assassiné
donc il y avait toute cette toute cette
vie et puis surtout ce ce choix de vie
parce que il choisit d'être de vivre
comme ça en clochard la vie de cet
artiste fascine depuis longtemps patrick
martin à ancien journaliste au berry
républicain
il écrit actuellement sa troisième
biographie et ne cesse de découvrir des
aspects de sa personnalité pour fête
basque où l'art et quelques acquis qui
adore se mettre en scène il se fait
prendre en photo mais très jeune et à
chaque fois ils posent notamment par
exemple cette photo là qui est on a
l'impression que c'est un acteur un
chevalier errant ou un moine avec une sa
robe de bure enfin un moine soldat ou
quelque chose comme ça c'est plus be2 de
s'habiller en femme on m'a dit
dernièrement d'ailleurs qu'il pourrait
faire pour y avoir un reportage sur lui
dans vogue bugs
international chez quand même étonnant
quoi ascou l'art était pourtant très
loin du monde de la mode dans les années
50 60 et 70 les commerçants les enfants
du centre ville non tous aperçu en train
de dessiner place gordaine où il avait
ses habitudes et dans la rue mirebeau à
l'époque jean-claude leboeuf était
bouché dans cette rue il le voyait
presque tous les jours
nous lui donnons rendez vous sur la
place qui porte son nom avec monsieur
bosco l'art on pouvait discuter de vos
coups de chaud enfin de beaucoup de
choses mais moi j'ai pas une éducation d
une instruction et ils se mettaient à la
hauteur de personnes voilà ils
reproduisent exactement ce qu'ils
voyaient et on pouvait prendre une photo
la comparer c'est exactement ça il ya
des gens qui sont amusés à compter les
rangées de pavés les rangées d'huile
c'est exactement ça voilà lui c'était de
la reproduction il est là l'erreur de ça
il s'amuse à faire des abstraits et
bizarrement bon ça peut paraître bizarre
un boucher qui ce qui se voit un des
abstraits est là ça m'a interpellé
et puis et puis voilà puis j'ai j'ai
collectionné une série d'abstrait
énorme on y en a je mets plus ou moins
mais il m'est donnée me donner mais
sinon on fait j'ai acheté il me rendait
quelques âmes qu'il avait besoin
d'argent sinon on faisait les changes
entre entre de la viande hachée puis
voilà ça se passait comme ça bascou la
revenait à la fermeture de la bougie
pour montrer ses dernières oeuvres et
parfois elles sont surprenantes
c'est quoi ça vous avait la v10 une
carte maritime charente maritime
il y des jeux complètent une carte
maritime et il m'a expliqué alors à le
soir tard il m'a est allé cette carte
non sur la caisse et tout m'a sorti un
livre comme quoi que notre nom droite
animé institude sur la carte une île
n'était pas mentionnée voilà donc lui a
mentionné à la plume langue de chine et
tous à la surface le l'auteur d'eau qui
tombaient dans l'année et tous enfin bon
voilà un peu plus loin au studio more
lie les portraits de bascous l'art sont
toujours exposés dans la vitrine comme
un hommage à l'homme que l'on voyait
passer sur son tricycle original basque
où l'art vous dites ici prendre un peu
d'eau ou discuter un jour il accepta de
se faire tirer le portrait par dominique
morlaix alors étudiant à l'école de
photographie de tours
nous avons fait toute une série de
photos devant le magasin avec son
tricycle lui tout seul en faisant sauter
en dessinant et donc sur portage de les
montrer à l'école à tour ils ont trouvé
très bien j'en trouvais vraiment qui se
dégageait quelque chose de ce personnage
bien qu'à tours il n'était pas connu à
l'époque dans les années soixante
quatorze il n'était pas connu du tout au
premier étage basse couleurs se faisait
photographier en robes des sciences de
pause bien connu dans la famille le père
de dominique et ses grands parents l'ont
même invité dans leur propriété d'argent
sur sauldre pour peindre l'étendue puis
il est resté deux semaines et bien sûr
il a refusé de coucher dans un lit et
chaise en garage dans le garage ou dans
notre propriété sur une fille sur une
botte de paille comme comme il était là
et il était ma mère nourrissez il avait
il avait s'était regaillardi avec la
nourriture parce qu'ils mangent ils
mangent rien si la belle feinte il
dessinait
les dessinait qu'il allait racheter une
tranche de jambon pour les chats étaient
pour nous
[Musique]
cet artiste vagabond cette figure de
bourges a inspiré bernard capo le
dessinateur a enquêté sur ce personnage
plein de mystère en 2013 pour les 100
ans de sa naissance
il lui a consacré une bande dessinée
enfin il a lui-même souvent croisé
basque où l'art dans les rues de bourges
ils se mettaient quelque part dans une
rue une ruelle une place de bourges
c'étaient pour dessiner donc mais je
n'ai jamais aussi comme beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais osé
trop approcher parce que je sais qu'il
n'aimait pas ça que d'ailleurs sur
s'approcher trop de lui il avait des tas
de de manille pour pourchasser les gens
kapo a reconstitué en dessin le drame
qui a marqué la vie de l'artiste
lorsque la mère de bascous la rtu son
père d'une balle dans le dos à saint
florent sur cher
il est alors âgé de 19 ans un
dessinateur qui raconte la vie tragique
d'un autre dessinateur regard admiratif
bien entendu parce que c'est très joli
ce qui fait j'avoue que j'ai un faible
pour ses peintures parce que qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus rares mais il avait un don
de la couleur extraordinaire qu'il a dû
abandonner un moment un autre peut-être
faute de matériel de peinture tout
simplement et on connaît plus sa période
on créa lancre il avait une maîtrise
pour restituer les volumes les ombres
c'était magnifique
les deux personnages principaux de
bourges c'est quand même jacques coeur
le milliardaire bon pied et vascular le
miséreux le diogène de bourges diogène
un philosophe grec qui méprisait la
richesse et les convenances sociales
un peu comme basque où l'art un esprit
libre que denise ans selon as côtoyé
tous les matins lorsqu'elle travaillait
au tabac-presse la civette
il est tenu pendant 25 ans la civette
avec ma belle mère et mon mari est
d'accord vous venu donc y venaient tous
les matins et laisser sa petite
charrette dehors
alors quand il se fait larguer comme ça
oui effectivement qu'il avait dont il
disait 8,7 qu'il avait des puces bascou
la relie le monde le figaro l'express un
clochard et lui dis en somme ils
venaient chercher ses journaux à satiété
c'était réglé et prenez ces jours nous
tous les jours ça c'était vraiment
régler un grand lecteur en fait oui
effectivement mais vous savez qu'il
était très intelligent il avait
connaissez cinq langues
quand même et qu'il a appris tout seul
en se débrouillant comme ça donc c'était
vraiment un personnage très intérêt très
intelligent un clochard provocateur qui
sévissent mettre sur son 31
quand l'occasion se présentait si vous
l'aviez vu en smoking olala noeud
papillon et tout accepter quelque chose
de formidable vous auriez pu dit même
homme rasé et tous les cheveux coupés
il était formidable
mais on santé les derniers temps on
sentait qu'il était plus pareil on
sentait qu'il qu'il avait quelque chose
qu'ils avaient peur de quelque chose
mais bon on ne sera jamais janvier 78
l'annoncé de sa mort est un choc pour
les berruyers marcel basque ou la mort
étranglé avec un fil de fer
son corps est retrouvé dans la boue à
côté de la cabane qui lui servait de
refuge avec ses chats les habitants sont
sonnés le dessinateur n'avait pas
d'argent il devait être enterré dans le
carré des indigents
alors les commerçants se sont rassemblés
ils ont fait une collecte pour les
offrir une véritable sépulture lui le
mécréant au cimetière saint-lazare ce
meurtre c'est l'une des premières à
faire de serge nonin l'avocat défend le
principal accusé jean-claude simion 23
ans un compagnon d'infortuné de bascous
l'art bon la brute le gros problème qui
se déposaient c'est qu'il avait à bout
et 1978
on avoue à partir de ce moment là
c'était la preuve majeur suprême on
pourrait former sans cause
et puis à la fin d'un interrogatoire
récapitulatif
hélas non c'est pour moi contradictions
jean-claude simion est condamné à 15 ans
de réclusion criminelle par la cour
d'assises du cher est envoyé à la prison
du bordiot mais le doute résiste au
temps est-ce que c'est lui là tout est
véritablement je ne suis pas sûr est-ce
qu'ils étaient plusieurs temps je vous
revois persuadé parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui était faible
visiblement il n'avait pas la trobe
enfin qu'il faut quand même de la table
je suppose pour porter quelques
adaptations de ses études et je pense
que c'était ici
il a été utilisé pour approcher base
couleur épuisée t il y avait un
phénomène de bande
vingt ans après sa mort les époux
charles est une association se
souvenir de marcel basque où l'art leur
salon s'est peu à peu transformée en
salle d'exposition permanente avec de
nombreux dessins à la plume
le premier bon saint-henri et après la
précision des de ses dessins a fait qu
on s'y est vraiment intéressé on a
cherché à en avoir toujours un peu plus
actuellement il prépare une grande
exposition pour l'anniversaire des 40
ans de sa mort en avril prochain
on fait les conférences ont fait les
expos fait beaucoup de choses
donc c'est comme ça ça va les gens
remémore mais vous savez si vous restez
un nom un an et demi sans rien faire
leur a plus rien
avec le temps 50 cent vols voici la
dernière ventes records pour un basque
où l'art une vue de la rue mirebeau
adjugé 6123 euros l'expert de ses
oeuvres
c'est michel darmancier il a toujours
des dessins en dépôt pour de futures
ventes aux enchères comme ce palais
jacques-coeur réalisée à la fin de sa
vie c'est plus suggestifs c'est moins
détaillé c'est ce qu'on appelle un peu
le fractionnisme fourchette de prix va
dépendre de nombreux critères un dessin
à la plume
simple sans couleur et des dernières
années on va dire
va voir une valeur entre 4 600 euros à
peu près quand on remonte dans le temps
et qu'on a des dessins plus anciens
toujours la plume
là on peut atteindre 6 800 voire 1000
euros
entre basques où l'art et les berruyers
l'histoire d'amour est compliqué rejeté
adulé incompris il n'existe pas de musée
basque ou l'arabe ou rouge
pourtant des lycéens de jean mermoz ont
réalisé un documentaire une
rétrospective est en préparation
un troisième livre en cours d'écriture
une reconnaissance tardive de son talent
la vie de cet artiste restera encore
longtemps comme ses dessins plein de
mystères avec des touches de clair
obscur entre l'ombre et la lumière